for the marlins it is zach thompson his
10th start of the season 10th start of
his career coming off a no decision
against the new york mets
and a swing and a miss goes to the
change-up for his first strikeout
two-way
zach davies with a record of six and
nine he's hit a rough patch lately
losing his last three consecutive starts
we go rojos will step to the plate five
but still getting starts every fifth day
rojas in the left that's going to drop
in for a base hit
and mickey takes an aggressive
turnaround first on his way to second
throws off the mark and rojas is
out and joe west the crew chief will say
that he is safe
ian half two walks big time homer late
in the game to get that opportunity just
go out there and play every day
happ has a base hit to lead off the cubs
second inning we're in the second inning
no score zach davies the 2-2
good fastball right on the outside
corner davies gets his first of the
night no score of the batter henry
alfaro i always felt like he was a very
fair umpire back there and if you were
to do that and hit the outside corner
three times in a row he's gonna go ahead
and call it three times in a row
three perfect pitches for zach davies
now the pitcher thompson batting that
essentially changed their entire season
swung on and missed thompson is retired
strike three two down
here in the last half of the third
innings
and a line drive base it center field
nikki rowe with another multi-hit effort
his 28th of the year
and he's got a double and a single let's
see if rafael can begin a cubs rally in
this fourth inning nothing nothing game
here's a swing and a smash into right
field base hit gets by de la cruz ortega
will go to third on the play
de la cruz gambled and lost
lead off triple for ortega
communicating with new york city where
they have all kinds of video monitors
and here comes the
call and they're gonna put him at second
base
so apparently
and you would have thought if indeed
this is part of the ground rules ryan
that that would have been discussed at
least to begin the series there's an
extensive ground rule discussion between
the managers and the umpires before
every series and then with every game
thereafter kind of a brief
ground rule discussion
but
apparently this was not discussed and
now david ross wants a clarification as
it would say
why all of a sudden are you sending my
man back to second gets by the sliding
de la cruz and gets lodged underneath
the wall which turns this into a double
wisdom grounded out in the first now oh
for seven in this series so he's due and
the one two
driven in the air right field base it
down the line over to pick it up de la
cruz as ortega scores
wisdom with an rbi single cubs lead one
to nothing two down nobody on the batter
brian anderson
and a catch by davies and just like that
the inning comes to an end odd inning a
catcher's interference a double play
a thrown bat and a batter stumbles over
it and a rocket back to the mound
one nothing covered
went away for
austin romine no two to roll mine a
swing and a miss a change up picked out
of the dirt by jackson fires down to
first to complete the cave here a ball
and two strikes
and gets him to swing into miss and a
curve ball once again they throw to
first and complete the strikeout
back-to-back gays and three on the day
five innings one run for thompson
completed
tonight one to nothing cubs in the
bottom of the fifth the 2-2
alfaro swings and misses strike three
one away here in the bottom half of the
fifth inning let's find out number four
for davies alex jackson the batter cubs
lead one to nothing here in the fifth
inning
sinker swung on and miss either a sinker
or a change it was breaking into the
right-handed batter back-to-back
strikeouts five for the game for davies
it was a change as i watch it again now
de la cruz grounded back to the mound
his first time
this year
in the left and a base hit for de la
cruz
that's a pretty nice adjustment although
this change up a little bit more out
towards the middle of the plate
saw de la cruz nodding his head after
swinging a miss and a changeup a pitcher
zach thompson at the plate
and he strikes out zach thompson with a
good sinker five shutout innings for
zach davies cubs lead one to nothing
we're in the sixth inning cubs lead one
to nothing
here's the liner into right base it down
the line over to pick it up de la cruz
alcantra will
hold with a single
lead-off base it for sergio as we go to
the bottom of the sixth inning in miami
from lone depot park cubs lead one to
nothing
here's the 3-2 swing and a miss and
davies has his seventh strikeout of the
game
there's that first walk aguilar is
aboard rinson will step to the plate the
tying run is on for the marlins here at
the sixth
ground ball too short alcantara goes the
short way but throws it wide
aguilar is going to head to third
and he'll stop right there
tough play for alcantara from the
outfield grass tried to turn
and find bodhi at second base to get the
lead runner in the final out of the
inning instead
throws it down the right field line and
the marlins will have the tying run at
third and the go ahead run it second
hello contra arranging
deep into the hole tying run is aguilar
at third
go ahead run is brinson at second
3-1
is
[Applause]
davies has been living by the change of
all night long you live by the change up
sometimes
well you might die by the change though
let this one up
and the letters
[Applause]
now this has been such a big pitch for
davies tonight to change up
above the belt way up 79 miles an hour
that turns into a batting practice
fastball flyers gonna
do something on the ground that's where
he looks to live
but romaine beating it into the ground
if you get him to hit it on the ground
you got to get him to hit it hard enough
or to somebody bromine hits it in just
the right place no man's land up the
third base line as you see hits the top
of the baseball like blair's hoping for
duffy waits first pitch line drive base
hit in a right field
vargas stops at second base and the cubs
now have
the tying runs on base with two down and
the dangerous rafael ortega duo the 3-1
outside he walked him
very patient at bat for ortega a couple
of those pitches were very close and he
laid off and now they're loaded
for frank schwindel base is full of cubs
two down
a bouncer fair down the left field line
it's gonna tie the game
two runs are in brenson throws it back
in here comes ortega to the plate
scoring
and the cubs have taken a 4-3 lead
a clutch three-run double for frank
schwendel
he was due and they went in there for a
third time back-to-back change-ups and
this one not better than the previous
one he's able to get the head out and
keeps it just fair as it crosses over
top of the bag and ortega the minute
that ball got put in play he was on his
horse all the way around the bases oh
for three tonight couple of ground downs
lined out to center as last time payoff
pitch coming
and jazz sits one down the right field
line that is gonna one up over the wall
a lead off double for jazz chisholm
junior here's louis princeton now
hopefully everybody
stays safe this weekend this a bouncing
ball to short behind jazz and it bounces
off of alcantara and the marlins catch a
break there might have been a tough play
to get brinson anyway given his speed
and the fact that it was a couple of
hops to short but either way
it is first and third and one out second
era tonight for alecandra my mistake
came in with none
this is a broken bat roller to short now
a run will score
well he had no errors at shortstop this
year and three tonight and the marlins
have tied the game now 4-4 and now
magneris sierra wide open space there
for sierra
instead pulls it into right field
brenson is getting waved around third
here comes the throw from fargus heads
up the line and the marlins take the
lead
circle change
out away out in front of it just a bit
but hit it hard to the right side
vargas a strong throw but offline bender
lives for the ninth inning here it comes
[Applause]
they go back and forth a few times
tonight